what message do you have to the fans who
have been patiently waiting for this
album of money it will definitely be
worth the wait people can interpret it
however they want but once it's theirs i
hope they enjoy it
well romani let's talk about this
partnership first of all because cracker
jill is coming through huh
yes she's coming through with vengeance
with full force
coming i feel like long time coming i
feel like very overdue but we're here
and i'm just really
honored to have been asked to be a part
of such a monumental moment you know for
the brand and one that we've loved for
so long right um
and just being able to represent women
across the board especially in sports
you know i'm a athletic woman myself i
grew up in
in dance and also in gymnastics very
competitive sports and um
i was just really inspired by a lot of
women at a young age whether that had
been in music whether that had been in
sports whether that had been in fashion
or
or modeling like
that representation to me is so key and
it's not every day that you get to
partner with a brand that aligns with
your vision and wouldn't
genuinely believe in isn't it amazing
that you can still apply what you learn
in gymnastics what you to what you do
now i mean you are a gymnast on stage
yes i was just talking about that i'm
like once a gymnast always gymnast god
knew yeah
doing flips and singing at the same time
no it's so cool sometimes i i really do
miss it i'm like i'm gonna have to go
back to the gym go back to my old uh
that old gymnastic stomping grounds and
get to the mat see what i could do but i
mean
i would probably not recover the same
problem
noah you're breaking a sweat dancing and
performing on stage so i think i think
you're getting your cardio in don't
don't you worry but i wanna also talk
about the fact that you got to not only
reimagine but put that normani swag on a
baseball classic
[Music]
play ball it was exciting you know
especially because
everyone believed in my abilities and
also trusted me with such a classic and
timeless record an iconic record um so i
wanted to keep it as close to the
original as possible while adding my
vocal textures and my runs you know to
modify it just a little bit it didn't
need you know much because it's like i
said such a classic and i didn't want to
lose the integrity of what the record
was
um that's the beauty of it so it was fun
though it was fun
shooting the music video it looked like
it was a lot of fun i would have never
imagined that you would cover this song
but that's what you oh right
yeah
but that's what you do so well you
surprise us you keep us on our toes
because i wasn't even thinking about
like you releasing fair
[Music]
you know i think everyone we know you
could do the up tempo and the dance
tracks in the box and we know you're
full choreo but you kind of strip that
away and release this very vulnerable
song which i have to imagine has to be a
little scary huh no absolutely freaking
terrifying
i always say that it's such a ballsy
move because
like i know what
people expect from me and i know what my
fans want but at a point too it's like
where do i fit into that you know i know
what it's like to put out records that i
don't necessarily believe in and to do
things that are
expected of me
but
i owe it to myself
you know
to put out records that really reflect
the growth
over the last three years that i've i've
had
and with fair i feel like it was really
the perfect record to
to be vulnerable and to
share my
most inner thoughts and feelings and
what heartbreak looks like for me you
know i'm still
introducing myself and yes everybody
knows like you said could
do the dance thing and i can
you know be this diva s confident
uh entertainer but there's so much more
and that's what i felt when i listened
to pharaoh i was like the money has the
range you know like i love that you're
putting that out now because we are
going to get the bops you know i know
that's coming and you even told me the
last time i spoke with you that the
summer is going to be lit so do you want
yourself oh yeah
yes yes okay like the stuff that y'all
want me to do is coming in the summer
okay
right exactly let us see he's into it
yes
which is why i said i'm like i'm gonna
put this out first because once i put
that out it's no turning back
i already know i know
i'm glad you did put it out and i know
you said being this candid on a song
like fair is uh sometimes uncomfortable
but now that it's out do you feel like
that vulnerability was worth it
i definitely do and i feel like it was
therapeutic in a way you know just even
shooting the visual it was
definitely triggering and it was the
first time that i feel like i was able
to really
tap into my acting abilities
which i'm really proud of myself
you know i think that
obviously there were slight nerves going
into because i'm having to really
emotionally go there and go back to the
place that the song was written from
which was incredibly
uh like i said triggering and hard but
by the end after all the tears and
screaming and
i mean you'll see it you'll definitely
see me take it there in this visual
piece but even just who i was able to
collaborate with it was really dope it's
i feel like it's one of my best
absolutely i'm i'm proud of it it should
be you should be proud of it do you feel
like you're still in that place where
you were writing this song or have you
kind of processed and worked through
those feelings not that about i wouldn't
necessarily say that i've worked through
them i think that i'm in the process of
um
just allowing myself to take it day by
day
and allow myself
the process
and journey to heal
i'm not fully there yet
yeah but i'm just
allowing myself to feel everything that
i need to feel the feels girl feel it
we're doing it with you too when you put
out something like that it resonates
with people because they know they know
heartbreak you know they know going with
those kind of emotions um but i do want
to talk about the fact that it's been
almost three years since you dropped
what would motivation say is the biggest
lesson that you have learned as an
artist of during that time to trust
myself
more
to trust my abilities and know that god
has given me all the tools that i need i
don't need to seek anything
i have everything that i need in order
to
step into the destiny that he's creating
and the path that he set forth for me
so i just need to do it you know and
you're doing it doing it
you know between the visual for
motivation and also just the vibes of
fair i'm getting some like 2000s early
2000s r b influence is that what we can
expect the sound to be like for the
entire debut album i would say
definitely in terms of like vocal
performance for sure
um and i have so much fun with my vocal
producer coop any time we're in the
studio like
his ability to just
totally from demo to like final
it's amazing to see how many phases of
record goes through in the evolution to
get to the final product and that's so
much fun do you think you'll give us
like a demo version like uh you know old
cuts of songs after the the album's out
maybe because my good must be different
let's hear the evolution
well speaking of evolution what is one
word you would use to describe this era
you are walking into normani
hmm
self-government you know what i can't
help but think that you know
you're coming at a time where there is a
lot of people rooting for you and a lot
of young female artists such as
yourselves but it wasn't always like
that when you think about brittany and
christina and like destiny's child
coming up what does it mean to kind of
be part of that way i mean i'm honored
you know to be chosen yeah
by the people
it means more than people think that it
means to me and it doesn't go unnoticed
you know like for someone that's always
felt very overlooked
and being the only black girl in
in a group
mentally was a lot for me and there was
times that i didn't feel seen and
felt unimportant and like my vocal
ability wasn't just as amazing you know
so to come out of that speaks to i feel
like my resilience
you know but also the people that have
just been riding with me since day one
like i'm i'm just grateful for it you
must be feeling that love because
whether it's some of your music idols or
your contemporaries i really do feel
like people are like
for nomani do you think they are
any of those contemporaries to maybe be
collaborating with you on this album i
know chloe recently just said she wants
to work with you somebody else just
mentioned that in an interview i think
that that would be really dope for us to
do something together
i love it i love it yeah i feel like the
um like we'd be limitless like there's
so much that we'll be able to do from
like vocally just choreography like
creatively just everything it would be
yeah y'all would break the internet on
that one that's for sure finally what
message do you have to the fans who have
been patiently waiting for this album or
money
it will definitely be worth the wait and
i hope you guys love it
just as much as i do i've obviously
spent
some years on it
very hard
um but more importantly i just hope that
they feel closer to me honestly that's
the beauty of music people can interpret
it however they want but
once it's theirs i hope they enjoy
[Music]